the hair looks great by the way thank
you thank you
we sure do is it like well doodoo lilacs
have more fun I've had a good couple
days it's only been a couple days it's
been fun yeah given you know where we're
at in the world right now I want to know
if you have had a chance to UM to chat
with your cast mates did you guys have a
have a wrap party you guys get to do
that no I mean we I mean yeah we've got
to do anything because it's you know
because everything that's going on right
now I've texted some of them recently
you know cuz we're all watching the last
season right now too because you know we
to to be able to talk about it so we're
talking you know exchanging texts of
you're so great this season you know
whatever so it's nice to be talking
everyone but um I definitely like yeah I
think the release day I want to be able
to call those guys have conversation
with them because we can of a party I'm
gonna at least have individual
conversations everyone about you know
just to reminiscing and congrats on the
show coming on everything like that you
know yeah yeah it's so interesting that
you get to experience a season even an
episode in so many different ways like
you get a script you get a table read
you're you're on set and then now you
all get to watch it you know if not
physically together together you know in
spirit or through technology what are
you looking forward to seeing would
experiencing when you watch this season
together I've seen it and I I'm just so
proud of everyone this year I think that
everyone's really incredible everyone's
doing the best work that they've done
yet truly and I think for me you know if
I can't watch it everyone that's like
I'm sort of sitting here sort of
celebrating them myself and I'm surely
proud of everyone you know and it just
it feels like a big deal that you know
this is a show that changed all of our
lives and we've spent so much time with
so it's it's bittersweet I'm excited
it's coming out but it is bitter in the
fact that I you know I can't see them
and we can't be celebrating but I know
we're all sort of celebrate
together alone you know yeah aside from
from changing your life and the lives of
your castmates it's really affected and
change the lives of a lot of people that
have that have watched it and it's
become more than just a conversation
about a show but the show has become the
center point of conversations around
teenage life around mental health as a
performer and you get to be part of
something like that you know what does
it meant to you what does it mean to you
I mean I mean I mean it means a lot I
mean especially because I feel like it's
rare to I mean in certain respects any
form of art can have a special
connection with someone I guess there's
things I could have done the past that
has helped someone for sure but not like
this it's I feel like it's once and it's
kind of a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
I think for a show like this to come
along or a project that can actually
really it started worldwide
conversations widespread and and really
made an impact and has changed a lot of
people's lives and I think helped a lot
of people and just to be a part of
something like that that actually feels
like a stamp in a period of time that
it's kind of unforgettable
it feels really special I definitely
don't take you for granted um you know
because I don't know if something like
that would come along again for me I
don't know but I yeah it's a really
really unique feeling but it I've loved
every second of it